this is session 8 the foundations and
finance module and in this session I'd
like to take the time value concepts we
used to value bonds and use them to
value residual claims or equity so let's
set the table when you're an equity
investor in a business you're the owner
of a business stockholder and a publicly
traded company an equity investor in any
enterprise what you have is a claim on
the residual cash flow what's left over
after everybody else has been paid it's
not a contract release at cash flow it's
not a promise cash flow and generically
there are two ways you can value the
equity in an asset or a business one is
to focus just an equity look at what you
get as cash flows as an equity investor
which as cash flows left over after debt
payments and discount those cash flows
back at a rate of return you would need
to make given the risk in that equity of
cost of equity the second way you can
value the equity in a business is you
can value the entire business the cash
flows to all of the claim holders in
this case both lenders and equity
investors it's called the cash flow to
the business the cash flow to the firm
and discount those cash flows back not
at the cost of equity but at a weighted
average of what the equity investors
want which is the cost of equity and
what the lenders want which is the cost
of debt it's called the cost of capital
and discount the entire business she
said how does that help me get to the
value of equity if you subtract out the
debt you owe you should end up with the
value of equity in a business there will
be plenty of time to revisit these these
concepts and examine them in detail but
let's set up the general picture in an
equity valuation here's what you're
trying to do the cash flows you're
looking at are the cash flows from both
assets in place and growth assets but
cash flows after reinvestment needs
which can be substantially we have a lot
of growth assets and after you've made
that payments interest payments and
principal payments to the extent that
you borrow money to fund some of your
projects think of that as a cash cash
inflow cash flows to equity our cash
flows that you face as an equity
investor the discount rate you use to
discount those cash flows will reflect
the risk you see in the equity and
remember again the notion of an
opportunity cost it's what you can make
on other equity investments of
equivalent risk what do you get as a
present value is the value of equity in
the business
now let's step back and think about this
cash flow stacking the cash flows equity
as I said our cash flows leftover after
every conceivable need as we met but if
you're a stockholder and a
publicly-traded from the company the
cash flow you generally receive from the
company
it's a dividend right the dividend if
the managers discretionary judgment and
how much the company can afford to pay
out it's observable it's right there and
not surprisingly the earliest discounted
cash flow models to value equity were
built around dividends because you could
build those but in effect what you're
doing when use the dividend discount
model is assuming that what gets fade
out the dividends is what can what the
company can afford to bear the more
generic the more general definition of
free cash flow equity it's not trust
companies when they pay dividends now
act as if those might not be what the
company could have paid and estimate
yourself what the company could have
paid a dividend I like to call this
potential dividend a free cash drawer
equity and yes what you're doing you're
looking at the cash flow leftover after
interest payments after debt payments
after investment needs after taxes the
way I describe it as is the owner of a
business this is the cash left in the
till after every conceivable need has
been met and remember remember unlike
dividends which are flawed at zero
cannot have a negative dividend your
free cash flow equity can be a negative
number and often if you're a young
company is startup a growing company it
should be a negative number so those are
your measures of cash flows let's talk
about the cost of equity the cost of
equity is the rate of return you as an
equity investor need to make not want to
need to make on this investment given
its risk it reflects what you can make
on otherwise similar equity investments
with equivalent risk so if you have
higher risk equity investments your cost
of equity should be higher in fact much
of what we talked about in the context
of risk measurement was setting up to
come up with the cost of equity so
here's the problem we raise this in the
context of risk and return models if
you're a publicly traded company with
dozens hundreds thousands of equity
investors each equity investor might
have a different cost of equity because
they're coming from different places
different perceptions of risk and that's
why we introduced
Shabba module investor the module
investor is the price setter modular
investors we remember own a lot of stock
and trade that stock the rest of us are
price takers in other words the modular
investors eyes are through whose eyes we
should measure that risk in equity and
that's the rationale we use for focusing
on risk you cannot diversify over which
we captured at the beta and that we
incorporate into the cost of equity so
the cost of equity discussion is very
closely tied to our earlier discussion
about risk and return and how it shows
up in a required rate of return so let's
take a very simple example of an equity
valuation model an old-fashioned
dividend discount model let's assume
Cornette which is a public you turn a
that serves much of New York City a
mature company paid dividends of $4 per
share in 2016 it pays out most of its
earnings as dividends which is what
mature companies tend to do as a mature
company serving a part of the country
which isn't growing that fast I'm going
to assume that Corner's earnings and
dividends are going to grow at about 2%
a year in perpetuity notice growth rate
of 2% a year in perpetuity makes this a
growing perpetuity let's assume the cost
of equity for this company which is
basically what marginal investors in
this company demand for investing in its
equity is 8 percent of everything I need
to value cornered stock I take the 4
dollars which is last year's dividends
but remember all perpetual growth models
require expected dividends next year
expected cash flow next beside grow it
out by 2% and then I divide by the
difference we might cost of equity is 8%
my growth rate of 2% the growing
perpetuate equation what I get as a
present value is $68 you're saying what
does that tell me
based on the dividend discount model
based on your perspective cash flows
being dividends the value per share at
Cornette is $68 you see the stock is
trading at 70 your going to conclude
that the stock is slightly of a value
slightly because it's only two dollars
off but the price is greater than the
value it's simple enough right
but remember when you use a dividend
discount model you are assuming that
Cornett is paying out what it can afford
to let's say that you have the capacity
to compute potential evidence you might
not right now but you will after
class but let's assume that you can
compute those cash flows leftover after
taxes reinvestment needs and debt
payments and let's say last year that
cash flow the free cash flow and equity
of potential divet was four dollars and
25 cents
remember cornet paid only four dollars
per share it could have paid for twenty
five and that's not uncommon companies
often hold back cash to value Carnot on
a free cash flow equity model I'm just
going to replace the four dollars which
is my dividend discount model number and
and I'm going to put in the four twenty
five everything else about the model
stays the same same growth rate same
cost of equity what I get is a present
value $17.25 I would view as my free
cash for equity value as we go through
this class I'm gonna argue that
increasingly you need to put your faith
and cash flows and not trust companies
to pay out what they can afford new and
dividends but an equity valuation you're
focused on cash flows to equity that
your discount back at the cost of equity
now I'm not going to go into the details
of firm valuation because it'll require
entangling ourselves with numbers were
not quite ready to entangle ourselves
with but here's the big picture to value
an entire business you look at cash
flows before debt payments in other
words you're looking at the collective
cash flows both lenders and equity
investors get from the firm
it's a pre debt cash flow you discount
the it's pre debt but it's after taxes
and after reinvestment needs you
discount that cash flow back at a
weighted average so what your equity
investors want which is the cost of
equity and what your lenders want which
is the cost of that's called the cost of
capital you discount the cash flows to
the firm at the cost of capital you
value the entire business and as I said
you really want to get to the value back
buddy all you need to do is subtract out
there so you can value a firm by taking
pre debt cash flows and that cash flow
will generally be higher than the than
the cash flow to equity but you're
taking a very different perspective and
valuation when you do it because you're
looking at all claim holders in the
fourth firm in the cash flows they
collect from those claims and when you
talk about a cost of capital you're
talking about a weighted average or
weighted average of what of your cost of
equity and the cost of borrowing money
and here's where the tax code kicks in
the tax code is tilted towards that
interest
payments and debt much in the world and
tax-deductible see her cost of debt
might be much lower than what you
actually see on your bank loan a five
percent interest in a bank loan might
translate into a three percent interest
rate after taxes if you have a 40
percent tax rate your cost to capital is
a weighted average of your cost of
equity and your after-tax cost of debt
with the weights being the market values
of how much equity and debt use this
firm eighty twenty ninety ten or a
hundred percent equity so the cash flow
to the firm discounted back of the cost
of capital gives you the value of the
business you subtract our debt you get
to the value of equity now I'm going to
give you some good news on on valuation
in a minute
but if you step back from both these
models the equity in the firm valuation
model you can also already see the
drivers of value in a business the
drivers of value in a business are cash
flows the expected growth in those cash
flows and this con trade you apply to
those cash flows and a way of putting
closure and part of the reason you need
closure is in a publicly traded company
of cash flows can keep going and going
and going forever and that's what a
terminal value does an evaluation is it
allows you to stop estimating cash flows
and generally use that perpetual growth
model that he saw for car net to get a
value at the end of the period but in
all valuation models it's all about cash
flows growth and risk those are the
drivers of value whether you do equity
valuation of firm valuation now you
might wonder when you value a company
should you value the equity directly or
should you value the business and
subtract our debt well if you do it
right if you make consistent assumptions
about cash flows debt and risk you
should get the same value for equity
using both approaches but I also make an
admission that's one of the most
difficult tasks in valuation is to stay
consistent as you move from one approach
another so we'll come back and address
this as we go through the process of
getting the specifics on valuation but
you have the tools to at least start
thinking about the value of residual
claims the value of equity in a business